there is a crisis happening here
along the border of belarus and poland
thousands of migrants trying to make it
deeper into europe had been trapped in
makeshift camps in freezing temperatures
for weeks
often without water food or medical
attention
thousands of people caught in the middle
of an intensifying geopolitical dispute
stranded in freezing conditions
human rights groups say that the harsh
conditions have already killed some of
the migrants
migrants coming to europe usually make
their way through countries that border
the mediterranean sea
but earlier this year poland lithuania
and latvia saw a spike in irregular
crossings along their landlocked borders
[Music]
when you take a closer look you'll
notice these crossings are taking place
along belarus's entire border with the
eu
and the reason this border is the new
epicenter of europe's migration crisis
is
one man
europe's last dictator
[Music]
in 2020 alexander lukashenko claimed
victory in belarus's presidential
election
an election widely believed to be rigged
backed by his main ally russia
lukashenko ruled for four prior terms
that were also considered fraudulent but
this time
the response was different
after the results were announced
thousands of belarusians took to the
streets despite the pandemic
to demand lukashenko step down
instead he responded with a brutal
crackdown and arrested more than 7 000
protesters
hundreds were beaten and tortured
four people died
and his political opposition was forced
to flee the country
lukashenko's nickname europe's last
dictator became more fitting than ever
the eu responded with sanctions marking
the beginning
of a dangerous struggle between the eu
and belarus the eu will impose
shortly sanctions
on a substantial number of individuals
responsible for violence repression and
election throat
despite this first round of sanctions
lukashenko continued to crush dissent
he used prisons across the country to
hold hundreds of political prisoners and
arrested 27 000 civilians
so the eu doubled down and imposed two
more rounds of sanctions
but lukashinko only got more aggressive
in may of 2021 belarus intercepted a
passenger plane as it flew over
belarus's airspace
after forcing it to land belarus
officials arrested a prominent
belarusian opposition journalist
he was allegedly forced to confess to
plotting riots on camera
as of today he's still under house
arrest
the eu countered with yet another round
of sanctions
this time lukashenko manufactured a
crisis at the border
to get back at them
migrants hoping to get to europe often
make their way to these coastal areas
and then take a dangerous boat ride to
european shores
it's an arduous journey that can take
days
many don't make it
but in the summer of 2021 a seemingly
easier path opened up
shortly after the fourth round of eu
sanctions lukashenko announced he
wouldn't be stopping migrants from
heading to the eu
it was more than just a warning
belarus hadn't seen a lot of middle
eastern migrants come through here in
the past
so the lukashenko regime created new
ways
to lure them into the country
belarus began offering tourist visas to
thousands in the middle east
especially in iraq
flights from istanbul damascus and dubai
on bellavia belarus's state-owned
airline more than doubled compared to
the same time last year
encouraged by belarus's open borders
thousands of migrants from war-torn
zones arrived in minsk
once on the ground reports show
belarusian guards bust them to the
border along latvia lithuania and poland
but the eu border wasn't open to them
all three countries declared a state of
emergency at the border and put up
barbed wire fences
looking for an opening thousands of
migrants eventually ended up here
at this checkpoint on the border
where things escalated
poland rushed thousands of troops to the
border to push the migrants back
they used tear gas and water cannons to
stop migrants from crossing
on the belarusian side border guards
wouldn't let the migrants retreat they
forcibly held them and pushed them to
try again as many as 4 000 migrants got
trapped in this violent cycle
they couldn't go back to their home
countries and couldn't go to minsk
either
those tourist visas were no longer
available to them
the eu labeled this hybrid warfare and
in many ways it is an act of aggression
belarus trapped the migrants
but the eu also failed the migrants by
ignoring its own legal code
which prohibits collective expulsions or
pushbacks
and guarantees minimum rights for
persons apprehended or intercepted in
connection with irregular border
crossings
contrary to the law
the migrants here were denied their
rights and pushed away
and
it's not the first time it's happened
in 2015 syria iraq and other middle
eastern countries were deep in conflict
forcing many to flee for safety
back then the safest route into europe
went through turkey
from there migrants could cross into
greece by land or take short boat rides
across
hundreds of thousands of migrants came
in this way
it was the largest migration wave ever
recorded in a single year
and the eu wasn't prepared
[Music]
so in march of 2016 the eu made a deal
with turkey
put simply turkey would hold back
migrants and take back any who made it
to greece
in exchange the eu would pay turkey 6
billion euros
with this deal the eu moved its external
borders from here to here
essentially outsourcing its border
security and legal responsibilities
human rights groups warned the deal was
reckless and illegal and made migrants
subject to human rights violations
still the deal went on to take effect
and migrant arrivals in greece plummeted
the deal was so effective in stopping
the flow of migrants
it soon took on a new geopolitical
importance
over the years turkey learned it could
threaten to let migrants in
in exchange for more funds from the eu
but it's not just turkey
europe has paid all these countries to
keep migrants from its
borders you'll notice they form a buffer
around europe that stretches from turkey
to morocco
in many of these places migrants are
subject to abuse and violence
including being pushed back to the
conflict areas they are trying to escape
but europe usually gets away with
pushing back migrants because it happens
here
far away and out of sight
and this gives all these countries
leverage and incentive to use migrants
as pawns
and that's exactly what lukashenko is
doing in belarus
to try and get the eu to drop its
sanctions
but it doesn't seem to be working and we
agreed
to expand the scope
of the sanctions regime on belarus
the road to the european union
does not lead via belarus
after weeks of escalation the eu adopted
yet another round of sanctions
and pressured airlines to cut off major
air routes from the middle east to minsk
belarus has finally admitted to moving
migrants to the border with poland
and has brought the migrants from the
cold camps to nearby warehouses for now
but lukashenko hasn't fully backed down
yet
in fact he's still encouraging migrants
to cross into the
euro that's because as long as the eu
continues to incentivize countries to
keep migrants away from its borders
leaders like lukashenko will find ways
to exploit them
[Music]
you